ايضا نريد ان نعرف تقييمات الجانب
الاسرائيلي لسيما انه ليس هنالك خطط فيما
يبدو لاعاده سكان المناطق الشماليه الى
المستوطنات
الشماليه صحيح نستطيع القول ان التوتر هو
سيد الموقف هنا في الجبهه الشماليه لا سما
وان المدفعيه الاسرائيليه تواصل قصف
البلدات الحدوديه اللبنانيه بين الحين
والاخر فقط قبل قليل سمعنا اصوات
الانفجارات الناجمه عن القصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي الذي يطال اطراف البلدات
الحدوديه في جنوب لبنان طبعا صباح هذا
اليوم تم الاعلان عن انفجار مسيره بالقرب
من المنطقه الحدوديه والتي تم اطلاقها من
الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه الجليل الاعلى
ما ادى الى تفعيل صفارات الانذار في كافه
بلدات الجليل ايضا سبق هذه العمليه اطلاق
صواريخ مضاده للدروع من الاراضي اللبنانيه
باتجاه بلده شلومي في الجليل الغربي ما
ادى الى سقوط صاروخ وسط البلده وبالتالي
تسبب باضرار على مستوى المباني السكنيه لم
يتم اعلان اي اصابات بشريه في هذه العمليه
طبعا كان هنالك تصريح لرئيس المجلس البلدي
في تلك البلده والذي قال انه باعجوبه نجا
سكان تلك المنطقه من الاصابه بشظايا
الصواريخ المضاده للدروع وطالب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والان يعني نسمع ايضا صوت
انفجار ناجم عن القصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي
باتجاه البلدات الحدوديه طبعا بالعوده الى
التوت الذي تشهده المنطقه نتحدث عن صواريخ
مضاده للدروع اطلقت باتجاه بلده شلومي
وهنالك مطالبات على مستوى الشارع
الاسرائيلي بتصعيد هذه المواجهه نحو حرب
شامله ودفع عناصر حزب الله بالتراجع خلف
حدود نهر الليطاني عبر الخيار العسكري
ولكن على المستوى السياسي الاسرائيلي
هنالك تعليق امال لربما على المساعي
الدبلوماسيه خاصه وان هنالك زياره مرتقبه
للمبعوث الامريكي الى المنطقه عامس هوك
شين والذي من المفترض ان يقوم بالضغط على
الحكومه اللبنانيه بتحمل مسؤوليه العمليات
التي يطلقها حزب الله وطبعا اسرائيل تقول
بشكل واضح على مستوى الحكومه ان هذا الوضع
يجب ان يتغير بشتى الوسائل وفي حال فشل
الخيار الدبلوماسي وفشل الوساطات الدوليه
سوف تلجا الى الخيار العسكري وهو ايضا ما
ينعكس على التسريبات الاسرائيليه التي
تقول ان هنالك وحدات في الجيش الاسرائيلي
بات يتم تسريحها من الجبهه الجنوبيه ويتم
نقلها الىى هنا الى الجبهه الشماليه تحسبا
لاتساع هذه المواجهه مع حزب الله ونحن
نتحدث اليك الان فاطمه حزب الله يعلن
مهاجمه انه هاجم بمسيره انقضاض مقر
القياده 91 للعدو الاسرائيلي في اليت شمال
الشرق صفد واصب الهدف بدقه ربما هذا هو
الحديث عن المسيره التي انطلقت من الحدود
اللبنانيه الى اسرائيل واعلنت القناه
الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه انها سقطت دون
اصابات ام اننا نتحدث عن حدث
اخر لربما يكون هذا حدث اخر خاصه وانه تم
الاعلان بالفعل عن انفجار هذه المسيره
بالقرب من المنطقه الحدوديه وتم التاكيد
على عدم وجود اصابات في هذا الحادث ولكن
خلال متابعتنا لمجريات الاحداث الميدانيه
هنالك تاخير بسبب فرض الرقابه العسكريه عن
الافصاح عن معلومات او احداث وتفاصيل هذه
العمليات خاصه ايضا البارحه يعني نتحدث عن
استهداف لتجمع جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالقرب من بلده ادميت الحدوديه في الجليل
الاعلى ما ادى الى اصابه خمسه جنود بجروح
طفيفه جراء استهدافهم بصواريخ مضاده
للدروع هذا الخبر يعني وهذه العمليه حصلت
عصر يوم امس ولكن الافصاح عنها ونشر
التفاصيل كان فقط عبر بيان لمتحدث
الاسرائيلي مساء يوم امس وبالتالي هنالك
فرض رقابه عسكريه وحذر نشر لتفاصيل هذه
العمليات التي حزب الله وفقط تصدر عن طريق
جهات رسميه الا وهي بيانات الجيش
الاسرائيلي وايضا هنالك تسريبات عبر وسائل
الاعلام ولكن دائما ما يتم اتخاذ القرار
ونشره ب عن طض الرقابه العسكريه نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا فاطمه خميسي من الجليل الاعلى